[Música]
ampliamos la información económica con
Daniela hablando y Daniela saludos para
usted Hola Ángela seguimos hablando de
la noticia económica que es el colapso
de silicon Valley Bank el presidente Joe
biden ya se refirió al tema aquí lo
tuvimos en transmisión en directo Sí
señora pues esta entidad bancaria
recordemos está enfocada principalmente
en startups o en recién nacidas empresas
tecnológicas el gobierno la interviene
el viernes después de que no pudiera
levantar recursos para solucionar
problemas de liquidez el presidente Joe
biden aseguró hoy que el sistema
bancario es seguro en Estados Unidos que
no va a haber rescates con dinero de
impuestos e hizo una seria advertencia
debido a estas acciones que ya se han
tomado por parte de nuestros reguladores
todos los estadounidenses pueden estar
seguros de que su dinero va a estar ahí
cuando lo necesiten
el manejo el director de este banco va a
ser despedido
las personas que están a cargo del banco
no deberían estar al cargo
las inversiones no van a ser protegidas
Ellos saben que tomaron un resto riesgo
y los inversionistas pierden el dinero
cuando esto sucede Así es como funciona
el capitalismo
eso es bien llamativo este mensaje que
da el presidente Joe biden porque esto
quiere decir que se responde sí por la
totalidad del dinero de quienes tenían
sus depósitos allí los ahorradores pero
no porque quienes tenían acciones de
este banco recordemos que este título se
desplomó en un 60% antes de la
intervención Así que quienes tenían
inversiones En este banco ya no tienen
nada graves Cómo se llega a este colapso
Daniela mire todo comienza cuando la
reserva Federal comienza en junio pasado
a subir agresivamente sus tasas de
interés esto para controlar la inflación
ahora vamos a ver lo cronológicamente
suben los intereses Entonces los
inversionistas son más reacios al riesgo
y prefieren poner su dinero en opciones
más estables por ejemplo los bonos del
tesoro de Estados Unidos Qué es un Bono
es como prestarle plata al gobierno y
que te devuelve en determinado plazo con
determinados intereses Pues con estas
tasas más altas muchas de estas firmas
tecnológicas prefirieron sacar sus
ahorros para satisfacer sus necesidades
de liquidez en lugar de endeudarse más a
tasas más altas que finalmente es el
negocio de los bancos ahora con mucho
sacando al tiempo el banco que tenía
muchos de los depósitos de estas
empresas invertidos en esos bonos tuvo
que salir el miércoles pasado a
venderlos de emergencia eran 21.000
millones de dólares el problema es que
esos bonos ya costaban menos que cuando
los compró Así que incurrió en una
pérdida de 1800 millones de dólares
después entonces para responderle a esta
gente ya estamos hablando Un día después
la empresa decide hacer una emisión de
acciones para recaudar más de dos mil
millones de dólares pero el mercado ya
estaba muy desconfiado Así que fracasó
esta emisión finalmente todo se derrumba
la acción se desploma en un 60% Porque
todos querían venderla y los clientes
protagonizaron lo que se conoce Ángela
como una corrida bancaria que es cuando
todo el mundo retira su dinero al tiempo
por pánico y ahí es donde el gobierno
decide intervenir y vamos en lo que
vamos el día de hoy muy angustiante la
cosa Daniela yaz lo dijo un poco joeyden
lo explicó un poco usted con su invitado
hace un rato qué va a pasar entonces con
el dinero de los clientes Bueno aquí
juega un papel fundamental la
corporación Federal de seguros de
depósitos que ya nombró un nuevo cirio
para este banco y traslado todos los
recursos a un banco puente en el que
todos los clientes podrán hacer sus
transacciones normales desde el día de
hoy al menos eso es lo que han dicho la
Unión Europea dice que está monitoreando
la situación pero que este banco no
tiene mucha presencia en la región y en
Reino Unido la firma o la rama británica
de este silicon Valley Bank fue
adquirida por parte de HSBC por una
cantidad simbólica de una libra
esterlina en una operación que facilitó
el gobierno escuchemos
nos enfrentamos a una situación en la
que podríamos haber visto desaparecer
algunas de nuestras empresas más
importantes las más estratégicas Y eso
habría sido extremadamente peligroso
durante la última década hemos
construido la tercera economía
tecnológica más grande del mundo por lo
tanto es muy importante para nosotros
como país que este sector prospere y es
por eso que el Primer Ministro del banco
de Inglaterra y yo nos aseguramos el fin
de semana de que tuviéramos una solución
Por supuesto que esto tiene un efecto en
los indicadores por supuesto la mayor
quiebra bancaria desde la crisis
financiera de 2008 paralizó las acciones
generó preocupaciones de contagio en los
mercados globales y tiene a los mercados
en rojo en Asia solo Hong Kong subió
pero el resto a la baja las principales
bolsas europeas llegaron a caer más del
3% al inicio de jornada y en Wall Street
se espera una apertura negativa después
de drásticos descensos el pasado viernes
en unos pocos minutos abre la bolsa de
Nueva York se espera también que con
descensos por cuenta de esta noticia ya
mañana usted me contará Daniela cómo
avanza el desarrollo de esta crisis
financiera Muchas gracias a usted así es
Seguiremos muy pendientes de esta
situación